I know I know I know that you're not
going to believe this but a trump
endorsed Maga candidate who lost
is saying she's having trouble
flushing her toilet
and getting it to properly flush
with only one pull of the chain for lack
of a better term
I if I told you that this was going to
be a topic a few years ago
Trump obsessed with toilets and people
he endorses obsessed with toilets I
wouldn't have believed it and I wouldn't
have expected you to believe it but in a
segment on Fox News Leo Terrell and
Tudor Dixon are on remember Tudor Dixon
was the failed Maga candidate Trump
endorsed who ran for governor in
Michigan
massive dumps of votes came in for her
opponent Gretchen Whitmer and Tudor
unfortunately for her did not become the
governor of Michigan but no uh need to
worry she still is weighing in on the uh
important political issues of our time
and those include
stoves Hannity is upset that they're
coming for his stove soon
and tutor isn't pleased with her toilet
this is considered political commentary
in 2023 listen to this well um Michigan
gubernatorial candidate Tudor Dixon
tutor I'll throw this to you first first
they want my stove now they want my
dishwasher what's next they're going to
take away my iron next I don't know
yeah well look I'm someone who does lots
of laundry I do laundry for six people
every week and so I know a little bit
about this and the last thing I need is
my laundry taking longer I'm already
dealing with a low flow shower head and
my kids are coming out with conditioner
smashed to their head like an old
Seinfeld episode and I have to tell them
to get back in and re-wash I can't even
flush my toilet one time to get toilet
paper down because of the low flow
toilets I don't need a low flow washing
machine folks this is more a segment for
a dietitian or nutritionist tutor is
missing some Fiber in her diet this
isn't about low flow low flow toilets
whose regulations have not actually
changed for a very long time how on
Earth did Republicans get obsessed with
toilets and remember this all goes back
why do right Wingers have so many
Plumbing issues you know with left-wing
people I know
no one ever seems to have an issue with
plumbing Plumbing's working beautifully
uh I'm actually having some Plumbing
work done soon I'm gonna I'm gonna ask
about this I'm going to ask my plumber
do Republicans struggle with toilets
more than Democrats here is the origin
of this when Donald Trump first said
he's got to flush his toilet 10 to 15
times we have a situation where we're
looking very strongly at sinks and
showers
and other elements of bathrooms yeah
where uh you turn the faucet on in areas
where there's tremendous amounts of
water where the water rushes out to sea
because you could never handle it yeah
and you don't get any water you turn on
the faucet you don't get any water they
take a shower and water comes dripping
out they're stripping out very
quietly have you ever seen when you take
a shower the water drips out very
quietly yeah people are flushing toilets
10 times 15 times as opposed to one it's
just as funny today as it was however
many years ago this guy is out of his
mind huh they end up using more water
so EPA is looking at that very strongly
strong you go into a new building or a
new house or a new home and they have
standards on where you don't get water
you can't you can't wash your hands
practically there's so little water
company you can't wash your hands so
let's add some reality to this I think
that for most of these people I mean we
know about Trump's diet I don't know
what Tudor is eating but we could take
some guesses
um this is really an issue of diet and
it's not actually an issue of plumbing
and sometimes it can be confusing but
it's really a diet issue to add reality
about the regulations what they are
talking about when it comes to the
shower heads is that the energy
Department under Biden decided to go
back to the standard from 2013. okay
about shower heads now the truth is it's
not really going to make a difference
Trump made a small modification that
allowed for slightly higher flow shower
heads based on how water per minute is
measured where instead of being per your
total shower it could be per device so
if you have like a rain shower head and
then a handheld you could have a total
of 2.5 gallons per I'm sorry you could
have 2.5 gallons per minute for each
each element
whereas the previous rules were 2.5
gallons per minute total so it's
basically going to change nothing what
Biden did because just about every
shower head on the market meets the 2013
requirements it's not like Trump changed
this and then all of a sudden every
manufacturer changes what they're doing
and then now they're going to have to
change it back and everybody who
installed is gonna have to it this is
just it's a made-up issue quite frankly
okay
the toilet stuff is even dumber because
there's nothing going on with that other
than I mean listen we know Trump was
trying to flush documents down the
toilet that might have been a factor in
the trouble he was having but this is
wacky wacky stuff and where we are now
is that Republicans go on Fox News and
complain one flush just isn't doing it
for me I don't know about you Sean